Paul Feig, the Director who has made "The Heat"
and "Bridesmaids" and "Spy",
and the best things ever in life,
he is delivering none other than "Welcome to Flatch"
which is your news series.
Tell us about it.
It's a docu-comedy in the vein
of "Modern Family", "The office", "Parks and Rec".
And what is really exciting about it,
it's based on a British show called "This country",
but it's also filled with people you haven't seen before.
And I think it's really nice to watch a show
where you get to discover a bunch of new, amazing comedians
'cause we sort of see the same faces over and over again.
And this is like new talent and the next generation
of brilliant people who you're gonna watch
for years to come.
I also just trust Paul Feig so much.
He's made some of the great comedies
and he knows how to balance heart and humor.
And to me, when you have the potent combination
of those two things, it's everything.
Yeah, we all need a laugh right now.
(audience applaud)
Is it true that you stole something
from "Welcome to Flatch?"?
Well, I wouldn't call it stealing.
So I eat a lot of PB and J.
You mean something a little like this?
Yes.
(audience applaud)
I often get them as snacks on set.
And so one day the director of photography was walking by
and she had a PB and J in her hand and I went,
"Oh, that's for me."
Because they tend to give me PB and Js
to keep my blood sugar up.
And I grabbed it out of her hand and took it
and ate it and then looked around and realized
that suddenly everyone had PB and Js and that I had just-
You didn't need to steal hers?
No, that was her PB and J
that I took right out of her hand.
And what I realized was because she didn't say anything,
I must be scary enough that she thought I was that person
that would just take something out of her hand.
It was an odd occurrence.
So will you play a little game with me?
Yeah.
All right, it's Q&A with PB and J.
(audience cheer and applaud)
All right, I'm gonna eat one too.
All right, take a big bite.
Which celebrity would be your hall pass and why?
Oh, well, I wish I had gone
for George Costanza from "Seinfeld."
(audience cheer and applaud)
You know, George's quest to have sex and eat a sandwich
at the same time is like my favorite episode.
Call me.
We're pulling a Costanza right now.
All right, a TV show that you recommend for us to binge.
What are you watching?
What are you into?
"Love Island UK".
(audience cheer and applaud)
What's your favorite ID account?
I really love The Dodo.
I love The Dodo.
Yeah, if I'm on Instagram,
it's 'cause I'm watching dog videos.
Have you ever woken up somewhere
and you didn't know what happened?
I have something called vasovagal syncope.
What is that?
That makes me black out.
Like without drinking?
Without drinking, if I hit my elbow in a certain way,
like I've fallen off a chair.
So I was on a stilt walk.
We were stilt walking through the forest
and I fell off the stilt.
So I woke up in the middle of the forest with stilts
on my feet.
I was not expecting this answer at all.
I know, a little less naughty.
I mean I blacked out, but I did it to myself,
if you know what I mean.
Well, I have to tell you Aya Cash,
I've had so much fun with you today
and I totally celebrate you,
and I'm so glad that you came here today, thank you.
Well, thank you.
(audience applaud)
And thank you for lunch.
Okay, I have to add, "The girl from Plainville"
is now streaming on Hulu
and "Welcome to Flatch" airs Thursday
at 9:30 Eastern on Fox.
They're both incredible.
Thank you for everything you're putting out into the world.
(upbeat music)